hey guys Pete here this is gonna be my
mr. robot season 3 episode 7 trailer
breakdown if you haven't seen the
trailer yet I'll put a link here at the
top that you can follow and watch it
first here we're just gonna look at the
frame by frame discuss what the
voice-over says and try to glean what we
expect to happen in the next episode the
description of the trailer on the USA
websites pretty interesting it says mr.
robot wants answers price less than rows
like a less than sign FBI closes in
night time in the desert night spelled K
ni ght Angela hits the rewind button
period a lot period so it's very
interesting little synopsis there and
the voice-over goes like this we hear
Krista say Elliot what happened exactly
he responds I don't know if I can say it
Leon's voice says relax calm down then
Angela told you everyone's going to be
ok she's saying that - Darlene it looks
like then we see mr. robot and Krista's
office and he says it's not me he has to
worry about it's the others the real
string pullers over top of a quick
sequence we hear what sounds like Dom
saying something's not adding up and
then the voice over completes with price
saying why come after me you got
everything you wanted visually the
trailer opens with Elliot staring at the
screen seeing the 71 buildings being
destroyed up from the end of episode 6
and we see him turn around pull up his
hood and take off let me get a shot of
him in what looks like Krista's Home
Office we hear Krista's part of the
voiceover go and we see her looking at
him in that same room then we see a book
of mug shots which has Elliot in it and
we can see that it's Tyrell that's
looking through the book and tell this
because later we see that he's
handcuffed to the table and the hand
next to the book is clearly handcuffed
in the same way so it appears that the
FBI is questioning Tyrell about who
Elliot is or
where Elliot is that's a little bit
strange when you think about it because
they know who Elliot is they know
through Darlene who's working with them
and Darlene's given us the impression
that there's some kind of deal in place
that includes Elliot so we don't really
know what the FBI is trying to
accomplish here if they're trying to
establish his loyalty to Elliot on the
other hand they could be saying we're
working with these guys and if you don't
give us what we want you're gonna take
the blame for the whole entire thing
then we see the desert and Leon is
driving that goes down when we hear his
voice over of calm down relax the title
of the episode is Frederick and Tanya
which we know are the two names that
Trenton and Mobley assumed at the end of
season two when they were in California
and the end credits scene this is sort
of the big mystery of the trailer I
would say because we haven't heard from
them Trenton seemed to think she had
none way of decrypting the files at
minimum at the end of the season but
there may be more to what she actually
said and now we see Leon driving and we
see him a couple other times but they're
noticeably not in any other shots are
they in the trunk well we'll see in some
other photos that it could be exactly
that but I'm not a hundred percent sold
on that idea yet because it's almost
like they're foreshadowing it's so hard
that it could be a red herring see that
Angela and Darlene are talking we see
Angela on the floor in her apartment we
can guess that this is a continuation of
their conversation at the end of episode
six this is post finding out that all
those buildings exploded but we don't
really know why Angela thinks that
everyone was going to be okay Darlene
looks intrigued but we don't really get
anything more and like I said we get a
then we go sort of a quick cut of a new
F Society video an aerial shot of Leon's
car with a clear grave dug in the desert
there we'll see him digging that later
but it's clearly the shape of a human
body the hole that he dug cuts back into
the F Society video
what makes you wonder who would be
making this one see Tyrell in the FBI he
interrogated again could see the book
there on the table we see a straight-on
shot of him where he looks resolved but
can't really tell what's happening and
the first one he could be crying he
could be finding out about his wife and
that whole situation but there's no way
to know for sure and then we see where
mr. robot is talking to Krista in her
home office and that's where we get that
part of the voiceover that it's not him
that he has to worry about he's
indicating to Krista that he's now on
Elliot's side and the common enemy is
the string pullers which we cut right
into price and white rose and those are
the people that I assume he's talking
about they appear to be having a meal at
what looks like Mara Lago as far as I
know still we see herbing in his shop
this ties into several of the other
shots we see here we see someone ringing
the bell over and over to get his
attention that should be an urban shop
and that should be mr. robot as far as I
can tell from the rest they keep showing
that as they cut to some different
things we see white roses assistant I
can't say for sure where he is in this
shot it could just be at the place where
we saw white roses in the past we see
mr. robot swinging open some doors when
I first saw this I assume this was at
Krista's and I haven't seen anything to
make me change my mind yet cuts back to
the bell ringing the bell again there's
a shot of Elliot up against the bookcase
that we saw in the trailer way back when
says he sitting there thinking about
what he's going to do shot a Tyrell
through the window still at the FBI and
this is where price is talking about why
did you come after me you got everything
you wanted an aerial shot of Leon
digging the hole in the desert mr. robot
in the back of the car and I've been
looking at this one because there's a
rough we can see someone in the
reflection I assume that
is him arriving at Urban's place because
we see him there in a second
but the person in the reflection is
wearing a suit so not exactly sure what
that means yeah the very next shot we
see mr. robot standing in herbing
service center lot can expect that
that's right before he goes in and
starts ringing the bell cuts back to him
sleeping in the car with the person
outside knocking on the window person
knocking could just be a driver it could
be someone that delivered him from point
A to point B just seemed weird to me
that you could see that he was wearing a
suit and then we get a couple of shots
of the harp player first from the end of
the season is the the harp player I
think is an indication that this is a
flashback to that same conversation
otherwise it could be just the same room
but I mean you can see price and white
rose in her minister Jang get up looking
at the heart player so it seems like
it's the exact same time as it was
before hopefully we'll learn more about
what they were talking about in that
scene in relation to Congo and
everything else remember this is just
post five nine the first time see Leon
sitting there with the telephone in his
hand and he looks to be waiting for a
call and then the trailer ends with Dom
looking at what I guess to be the board
on the FBI wall of the investigation so
this gives us a lot of ideas of where
the final third of the season is headed
but it is a pretty mysterious trailer
overall as far as the Leon stuff and the
angelus stuff it gives us an idea that
we're really gonna figure out why angela
is doing what she's doing when she's
talking to darlene and i kind of hope
that's the case but we can't say for
sure clearly if 71 buildings blew up and
there were a thousand people dead that
doesn't equate was what she's saying
that i told you everyone was gonna be
alright so this could be a key moment in
understanding Angela's character if it
plays out how the trailers leading us to
believe it is with Leon we could be
finding out the fate of threatenin
Mobley the desert I mean it looks out
west that's out west that's not in New
York you know so
wherever he's doing involves a situation
in the western part of the United States
the show title mentions threatenin
Mowgli's names but is that enough to go
off of the fact that they're definitely
dead I hope not I mean I hope they're
not I hope they don't die off screen at
least I hope there's more to it but how
do we know we do know that they were
crossed out on the FBI's board but that
doesn't really add up either so those
are my big takeaways from it I mean I
think it's interesting that Krista comes
back into the picture because she can
also bring out mr. robot and talk to him
I'll be curious to understand if they
are going to be on the same side I mean
that was sort of the cliffhanger before
the cliffhanger in the last episode was
now that they did work together to save
the building in Manhattan what would mr.
robot do this seems to be that he is on
Elliot's side but to what end you know
we have really no idea and it does say
in the thing that the FBI is getting
closer so they probably will be learning
some important information from Tyrell
they may also be getting an idea that
Santiago is working with the dark army
but we're gonna have to wait and see the
way the seasons been going I can't wait
let me know what you guys think about
the trailer in the comments please like
the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already make sure you turn on
notifications so you'll know when my new
mr. robot videos come out follow me on
Twitter or my other social media
accounts so we can interact over there
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon